before this i did not know what investor
was but i just thought they had the
coolest job in the world and like it's
so amazing that they get to wake up
every single day and you know meet with
founders that are trying to make the
world a better place than it was
yesterday
[Music]
jill clinvex thank you for joining my
show how are you today i'm doing well
michael thank you for having me long
time no see
long time no see i believe the last time
we saw each other we were 16 17.
i know i think yeah i was 16 i think you
were 16 as well we were both at mit
trying to work on our first startups it
was a good time
diedomi if i remember correctly yeah you
you remember it and you were doing any
meal
and you remembered okay so you know
those are our fun
our fun stint at in high school and we
both
met at the mit entrepreneurship uh
program uh launch x
uh uh with a wonderful instructors and
cohort and then
we're still in touch today so it's
really really great to see now and and
obviously
you know we both went on on different
yet similar paths we
are both really passionate about you
know working with startups and
with uh seeing what's happening in the
world of technology and how
uh we can leverage you know innovation
to really make the world a better place
and i think that the work that you're
doing is principle at capital
factories really is really incredible
and i can't wait to learn both about
your journey learn about
you know texas and and the venture
capital space over there
and and some specific things that you're
particularly passionate about so
jill get me started off about your
journey and
go even further back than mit what gets
you into the mit program
and since then how do you get to the vc
space yeah absolutely so
before i went to the mit program i grew
up in very small towns and i think for
many of us that have grown up in small
towns you get
bored and also curious um and so
my dad at one time was taking a business
trip up to boston and i had some time
off of school and so he's like
hey you want to come join me i figured
you know why not i'd never been to
boston
and uh i remembered actually funny
enough in my
son about silly but from watching
legally blonde there's a little girl
that el woods went to harvard and so i
was like
wait harvard's in boston i should go
check it out and so i did a little
college tour while my dad was working i
went to harvard mit bu um
and i was so impressed with you know
what the schools were doing and i was
meeting people who i found that i had a
lot of comments i have to stop you jill
yeah because
i don't know if you know this but i was
professor callahan and legally blonde
in high school the year after a launch x
and i actually when i when i went to
visit colleges myself i actually
sang the song blood in the water
in the harvard law school auditorium wow
okay
just go figure i i would have assumed
you would have done it
what have you not done well i think you
know legally blonde it was a great movie
and i think it inspired a lot of young
women because
you know some of us are ourselves then
you know the good old el woods so
um yeah i did a lot of these college
tours met great people
and um funny enough when i was there
you know i was talking to different
professors and they're like well you're
still a few years out from applying but
um a lot of these colleges and
universities offer these summer programs
and so i figured you know why not apply
to one but um
i let's see i think i initially applied
to one at harvard and i found it very
interesting and then
i just so happened to get like a flyer
from this new mit launch x program that
was starting
and i was like oh my gosh mit like i
don't think i could get in there but
what the hell i'll try and ended up
getting into the program
and um went to go spend the summer in
boston and that's where i met you and we
were able to work on our startups and
you know do some really exciting things
there and i think what
was so unique about that program is the
exposure that it gave you know young
people
to you know the wonderful world of
startups and venture
and you know i think as young people
were often taught you know you can be a
doctor
a lawyer a teacher but there's really so
many careers that are out there and
you know you can be your own boss or you
know do something that's a little bit
untraditional and so
when i was there i was exposed obviously
to you know starting a company and
a big part of the program as you know
was pitching to anyone and everyone and
telling your idea
and at the end of the program it
accumulated with um i guess included
with
pitching to investors and um
before this i did not know what investor
was but i just thought they had the
coolest job in the world i'm like it's
so amazing that they get to wake up
every single day and
you know meet with founders that are
trying to make the world a better place
than it was yesterday
um so i just knew from then on like
that's like
yeah we hope hopefully they're not just
going after some crazy returns but
um you know i just really inspired by
what they were doing and so
i decided that i wanted to get into bc
and found a little bit hard to break
into
so um started a few companies along the
way just to kind of
catch the eye of investors and ended up
starting a platform that helped
investors evaluate investment
opportunities and
ended up getting my foot in the door and
i spent let's see my first
gig in vc was um as an analyst at a vc
firm in new york it was a private family
office run by michael loeb who
actually dropped out for a year in order
to do that right yes
i did i did low risk high reward i know
you took a few years off yourself
um but you know if you get the
opportunity to drop out of school for a
bit i highly recommend it
you know i think it really helps you you
know learn what you want to do in the
future and it's a nice kind of trial run
and
a safe environment so um i joined loeb
enterprises in new york for a few years
and
left school and then ended up going back
to school finishing off my senior year
of college
and then got a full-time offer to join
capital factory in austin and so that is
where i am now
wow okay that's a lot to take in but
fast forward to
to capital factories so you're a
principal investor there you've i
believe you saw something
over 80 deals right with most of them
having at least one minority founder so
first of all
you know young vc energetic you know
you've seen some of the startup space
yourself
you're in texas why austin why choose to
be in a vc
in austin i i don't know austin at all i
know that it's a crazy crazy opportunity
to
to be there now but but why go there
yeah absolutely it's a great
question and it's it's one that we get a
lot but
um you know austin has been one of the
fastest growing metro areas
in the country for about nine years
straight um and over the last you know a
few years we've added over 500 000
people to the city so
we're seeing no entrepreneurs tech
employees and just overall ambitious
individuals that are flocking to austin
um i personally moved here a little bit
less than two years ago from new york
um and you know i think it's interesting
because once covet hit
it really accelerated the trend that was
already happening so
i'm sure if you read the news headlines
you'll see it but every day there's you
know a new
uh celebrity a new venture capital firm
a large corporate headquarter that's
relocating to texas
um over the last few months we've seen
you know hp we've seen oracle announce
their new headquarters in texas
we've had elon musk joe rogan and tim
ferriss move here
um most recently abc and briar capital
moved their firms here as well
and so you know i think austin is sounds
like i should be moving there
you should be i don't know why you
haven't done it yet you're always ahead
of the
trend um i'm gonna take that to heart
good well you always have a place to
come stay here
um but you know austin is and will
continue to be an important startup city
we have ut austin at you know the heart
of the city which is
definitely a theater institution they
produce a ton of future ceos
leaders and just top talent that ended
up going on to you know work for the
tech companies here
um you know many corporations have their
corporate and regional headquarters in
austin so
we have for example oracle whole foods
facebook
ibm silicon labs i mean the names are
endless but
all these companies really attract top
talent from across the globe
um that you know move to austin and
maybe stay for years of those companies
but then they go on to innovate and
create new technologies here
and so it's it's really amazing to see
all the talent that is here and i think
overall um talent attracts the companies
uh you know the corporations and
um it's just really wonderful but i
think at the same time with austin
growing so rapidly in just the other
toxicities overall
i think it's you know we need to
continue to have our local politicians
uh work with tech entrepreneurs to
continue to make austin a desirable
place for
um you know entrepreneurs and
corporations to come work together so
making sure there's still good tax
incentive incentives you know having an
international airport
being able to do these things that
continue to make austin a great city and
attract more talent here
i think that's just so cool but you know
on the other side so that's one very
special thing that you're doing but
you're also really focused on
on on bringing underrepresented groups
as founders and and backing them and
supporting them and
you know the 2021 and to say at least
you know we're
we're in a time period where you know
these things are in the headlines
you know every single day if not if not
more if not more than that
and what is your take on you know
the fi funding space in general what is
what have been some of the trends
how do you end up sourcing so many deals
through underrepresented founders is
that intentional is that
you know because of your location what's
happening there yeah
i think you know for me uh just being a
woman in bc you know women are
underrepresented in the landscape and so
for me it's
always been near and dear to my heart um
and
you know a lot of people might say it's
a pipeline problem i strongly disagree
with that but
i would say my particular area of focus
has been on underrepresented
underrepresented founders for many
reasons but um
kind of a few staying out to me in
particular i'd probably say three are
kind of a top of mind but you know one
is minority founders have been
underrepresented in the venture
capital landscape since the beginning of
time um you know in 2018 only one
percent of entry dollars went to black
founders in about two
point two percent yeah the numbers are
wild if you if you read all the studies
okay i didn't know it was that bad
yeah and about point two percent went to
black female founders
um and then just from you know this most
recent year from 2019 to 2020
the dollars that were allocated to
female founders decreased
so i really think just reading the
numbers overall should drive us to
action right
um and number two i'd say
underrepresented teams they financially
perform better
and you know it's no secret vcs are in
the business of making money
um but there's a ton of studies on this
topic but one of my favorites was done
by boston consulting group
and what it the conclusion of it was
that you know for every dollar of
funding
that is um invested in a startup that's
founded or co-founded by a woman
they generate about 70 cents on the
dollar versus if you're going to invest
into a male founded startup
they're going to generate about 31 cents
on the dollars and foreigners
yeah it's pretty wild but you know for
investors why do you think that is or
what are they why what do they say about
that you know some of the things and i
think just the
things that they say and also you know
my meetings with female founders is
i found that they're very scrappy and
they have to work with limited resources
you know they don't have as much access
to capital
they're not in all the networks that
maybe you know male founders are
and so they have to learn how to do a
lot with a little
um and so i think they're you know
really good at doing that
um and you know last but not least i
think it's just you know the right thing
to do to invest in minority founders you
know
we need more minority founders shaping
the future of our world you know we need
more opinions
we need more voices and i think you know
we need to continue continue to not just
be open-minded but also to support and
invest our dollars into those groups
right i think one of the big one of the
big takeaways from 2020 has been that
you know by being
and obviously we have the whole black
lives matter movement and everything
that
one of the key things that it shine was
you know it's not just about you know
being open-minded but
being a bystander and not taking action
is a part is being a part of the problem
really
you have to be intentional about what
you're doing and we're seeing so many
companies that are prioritizing on
hiring
for diversity not just because their
their their talent is just as good
but it also promotes better culture it
promotes better understanding and better
a better humanity within the company and
you see a lot of vcs that are now saying
we will only invest in companies that
have at least
one female co-founder at least one
co-founder of a minority status and so i
think that
you know definitely being intentional
it's not something to shy away from
and i think that there is a question
that needs to be made and i just i'm
personally inspired by but you know your
your passion and ambition for doing that
and
so most of the deals that you've sourced
actually were
from underrepresented communities right
yeah
over about the last year at capitol
factory i brought in about 55 companies
to our portfolio
um and 87 of those were run by a
non-white male founder
and then in particular um the
the targets that i have for you know
particularly underrepresented groups
that have less access to capital than
just non-white males are
latinx black female lgbtq veteran
and then also disabled individuals and
about 55 percent of those companies
um were founded by those targets um
so yeah it's been really fun you know to
to work with all these different
communities and i think
you know for so many of us we you know
we're surrounded by
uh you know different groups and
networks and they tend to kind of create
that vicious cycle i'm sure you've seen
you know warm intros
are kind of the bread and butter of the
vc world you know if you can get a
warm intro it's kind of like your foots
in the door um
but i think in the same kind of vein
that warm intros create this vicious
cycle of you know who knows who
and so personally what i love doing is
just putting my time out there
for anyone to meet with me um you know i
kind of set a little bit of criteria you
know i'm looking to meet with seed in
series a companies and xyz industries
um but you know being able to just let
anyone and
everyone you know meet with me and be
able to to chat with them is has brought
in so many more opportunities than just
the warm intros that i received from
you know friends in the industry right
so so one way one thing that i'm hearing
from you is by you first opening
yourself up to
single cam oh i'm not just going to be
intentional about you know
uh partnering with minority founders i'm
actually going to be intentional also on
working with people that wouldn't have
necessarily access
to my you know to a warm intro and i and
i just love that
but you know more broadly now about
capital factory and
tell me a little bit about about what
you're doing there what is sort of the
thesis how do you work with
funnels one of the things that i love
about the show is also getting to know
really you know the behind the scenes of
how things operate so you know when you
work there
like what is the process like and what
do you really enjoy doing over there
absolutely um so a few of the reasons
that i you know chose capital factory
overall
was its emphasis on diversity and i
think it you know it really helps
my uh job overall that you know the
partners that i work for uh care just
about as much about diversity as i do
um but for those who don't know about
capital factory it's the most
active early stage investor in texas and
so um we
we invest in more deals than any other
investor in the state
so it's you know really high deal flow
volume
um and while we are an industry agnostic
firm we'll
invest in almost anything we've done
healthcare cpg
you know medical devices b2b sas
companies
um over the last few years defense has
also been a huge push for us and so
um for those who haven't been into our
office our eighth floor of our austin
office it's called our center for
defense innovation
and uh there we have you know the air
force the
army we have folks like booz allen
hamilton and
and other uh prime contractors and so
it's a really cool place where
uh investors startups and uh defense
orgs and government orgs are all working
together to produce and create cool new
technology and so
um that's one of my you know favorite
pieces about capital factory but
um you know first and foremost we are a
vc firm but we do have other programs
um what we call capital factory ventures
which you can kind of compare most
similarly to an accelerator
but um we do have other programs that
help and support
early stage founders um and our thesis
is really on taxes we are so excited
about what's going on here
and uh you know there's just so many
startups blocking here so our goal is to
really continue to invest and support
the texas ecosystem um and make it you
know
the greatest state for startups i i just
love that i really do love that
and what is sort of the relationship
that you have with these funds so first
of all
obviously there's a trade-off the more
companies you invest in you have you do
have limited resources and how you
cooperate with them so
and you do go very early stage so what
is the relationship like and what is
sort of this you know non-contractual
agreement that you have with the
founders
as you go into this partnership
absolutely it's a great question
um i think you know in the earlier days
it probably looked a bit different
but now that we've achieved such scale
we have created a really amazing
and supportive ecosystem around us so i
think if you look at most vc firms they
probably look like five partners and
their secretaries but
um capital factories quite a bit larger
we have you know
an events and programming team we have
an investor relations team we have a
you know capital factory ventures team
that's more like kind of that platform
accelerator piece to our business
um sorry my dog is interrupting give her
a quick little treat
um we love dogs i know that wait did you
just give her a treat through a phone
oh no i have a whole jar sitting next to
me ready
i thought it was one of those really
cool apps where you just click on the
click on a button and it shoots a treat
from another device
that's for the next episode yeah next
time i think she'd be too smart and
probably uh
take take it down and take all the
treats um
she's an interesting one she's my
quarantine pup um
but yeah i mean you know kind of what
our agreement looks like with those
companies is we do make investments
but we also provide a lot of value
outside of that capital piece right so
anyone can give you a check but what can
they actually help you with um
and so we we provide a lot of resources
i'd say the top three things that
are universally uh you know universally
known what startups need is
generally access to talent customers and
money and so those are the three main
areas that we support so
in terms of talent you know we're making
sure that we can
um help introduce them to their next
co-founder or the next cto or say
they're like
hey we need five sales you know sales
reps to start like let's go out and help
you find those folks
um in terms of money we have an investor
relations team whose sole job is to help
them fundraise
so you know if they're saying hey we're
going out to raise our series b round
you know
who are the top five lead investors we
should go after who's that other
strategic capital
um that's our investor relations team
job is just to solely help our portfolio
companies fundraise um
in terms of customers we have a large
corporate innovation council think of
these fortune 500 companies that
are looking for access to work with
startups we have all the government
organization
uh organization relations relationships
and then
also we have 200 plus mentors that work
with us and
our daily offering their you know office
hours these companies and so
um you know all of our mentors are
accredited investors or have exited a
company in the past and so
they're all very talented and qualified
so it's really helped us achieve scale
um and be able to support all these
companies because our portfolio has
gotten quite large
i just i just love that so how many
companies in total are in the capital
factory portfolio
so between our accelerator and our
investment fund it's roughly around like
900 ish
whoa yeah that much that's uh
literally blown away what just happened
there
jill you know 20 minutes go by way too
fast but i really thank you for taking
the time to do this
uh thank you for keeping in touch all
those years it was like
it was seven eight years ago and i just
love the work that you're doing i think
that you are
i think that the message that you're
putting out there is is fantastic both
for young women that are that are you
know the ill words that are pursuing
these that are
interested in and can pursue this type
of career and i think that we're you
know
dropping out of college for a year to to
take that opportunity to be
an analyst in in the fund in new york i
think that really is a is a
strong statement about what it takes
sometimes to
to leverage these opportunities and at
the end you know
when presenting these opportunities i'm
all about jumping on them and taking
them
and so i love that that's what you're
doing and that's what your journey has
done so thank you for shedding light on
that and obviously you work with
underrepresented communities is
incredible
before we leave i have the most
important question three words that you
would use to describe yourself
well this is a good one um for me i
would say you know first would be
intentional
second would probably be goal oriented
and third energetic
those are the three that i choose i love
that jill thank you
very very much and stay safe and stay
healthy and i can't wait to see
what awesome things you're going to
continue doing oh thank you michael and
i appreciate you having me on it was a
pleasure catching up
and chatting more
you